gehen sie noch selbst tanken wissen sie
wieso der benzinpreis super zum beispiel
ich gehe nicht selbst tanken ich darf
nämlich in wahrheit gar nicht oder ich
darf schon aber ich werde richte mich
nach der empfehlung aus
sicherheitsgründen nicht selbst mein
auto zu fahren und das ist auch eines
das sich auch nur schwer bewegen könnte
weil es auch ganz besonders schwer ist
aber wissen sie ungefähr wo der
benzinpreis ist nicht ganz konkret immer
wo die benzinpreise sind weil ich ja
nicht jeden tag darauf gucke und ich
habe ja auch ein ganz ordentliches
einkommen deshalb bücher nicht zu den
leuten die jetzt immer auf den letzten
die also ganz genau bei jedem preis
hingucken also da könnte ich ihnen auch
nicht viele preise konkret sagen